Cisco gave this to me before I left
central city it's the only way I specie
could get drunk is off of this rocket
[Music]
hey everybody grab a flask of Cisco's
rocket fuel because wall-e is officially
a legend as of the end of the episode so
let's break it down appropriately there
is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video obviously they're pushing
into the mythology much heavier because
there's only six more episodes in the
season but there were actually a bunch
of flash Easter eggs mostly just because
wall-e is part of the series now so of
course they're gonna be referencing
flash stuff from the comic books quite a
bit so just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet top 10 and
Easter eggs
number 10 the totems explainer they
briefly mentioned a mystery sixth totem
I've talked about that in one of my
previous videos there's an episode
titled necromancing the stone coming up
it might have something to do with that
mystery sixth totem that might have
something to do with bringing all five
of them together and the reason why Ray
Palmer knows about the whereabouts of
the fire totem is is because he crossed
over with that vixen animated series
which takes place before Laurel died on
arrow because she crossed over to that
series and that's canon to the
live-action series so when ray is
referencing all this totem stuff it's
because he learned it while he was with
the vixen character on that animated
series stray observation apparently
Mallis looks like a hemorrhoid even
though we've never seen him before
John Noble himself that does the voice
of the character is actually gonna guest
star himself on the show but they said
that he'd be playing a version of
himself he's not gonna be playing the
Mallis character when he actually
physically comes on the show number nine
was that whole Ava Sara date storyline I
wasn't sure what they were doing with
this and I actually expected it to be
much worse because it felt like it was
completely out of the tone of the energy
of the rest of the episode but you could
kind of see how they were trying to
build tension between those two
characters towards the end of the
episode as like everything else was
getting crazier and crazier until it
erupted in that sword fight on the
Waverider so that's the moment that they
we're building towards but they are
full-on confirmed doing it now like hey
let's find a room is there a room around
here somewhere where we could spend some
time there are a couple weird moments
where it feels like they write her as if
she's 15 years old and this is the first
time she's ever been with a woman like
they're completely forgetting about the
fact that she was with Nyssa for many
years so this isn't the first time that
she's been with a woman she's bisexual
so she's been with men women it's not
that big a deal so it does feel kind of
weird that the show is making her
relationship that big of a deal
also straight observation this is kind
of a WTF is they've been spending a lot
of time in Star City in Central City the
last couple of episodes and if they
don't mention it on arrow at some point
I'm gonna be a little upset like you
spend that much time doing crazy things
crashing the Waverider into star city in
present day why wouldn't the arrow
characters mayor Oliver Queen in
Felicity who has control of all those
satellites not notice something like
that
number eight they go after the fire
totem in Detroit in present-day they
don't include vixen in the episode they
briefly mentioned her because the
actress is busy on another TV show but
they meant to imply that she's running
around beating up criminals while
they're going after the fire totem maybe
someday we'll get some sort of vixen
team-up it's just a question of both
actresses being available at the same
time but if it wasn't clear damian
darhk-- made off with the fire totem
before the legends could get it that's
what the note was about then number
seven later he steals a Mayas totem and
he says three is a charm so he has three
of the totems because that also includes
the water totem that Cabasa has but this
is mostly just damian darhk-- and his
daughter in this episode zari still has
the air totem so the mystery sixth totem
that nobody really knows anything about
is the only one that's left to be found
but number six we finally get some more
wally west it's basically a follow up to
the scene that we saw at the end of last
week's episode with rip trying to
recruit him and it's a bit of a long con
like you can tell that wally is kind of
in meditation just trying to get his
life centered in rip hunter or needs to
get all these objects from the time
bureau and he needs some more help to
fight Mallis and all these big problems
so he knows he needs wally but while he
doesn't want to come so it's a bit of a
long con trying to convince him to the
episode but we find out that jesse
quicks favorite song is George Michaels
Careless Whisper and Wally quotes fast
and furious but number
five was the flash karaoke sequel so if
you were confused why they went to 1990
to Tokyo I think this is meant to be a
Mark Waid Easter Egg because around that
time George Michael late 80s Early 90s
was around the peak of his popularity
because George Michaels Careless Whisper
was the song that they were seeing at
karaoke but also in the comics 1992 was
the first year that Mark Waid started
his flash run he wrote flash for eight
years it was all wally west era the very
first stories that he wrote during 1992
was basically a retelling of Wally's
origin story it was called thunderstruck
the name of the first collection that he
wrote was born to run so it was kind of
him soft rebooting the Wally West
character for the modern era so because
this was Wally's sort of soft reboot
with the legends I feel like that's what
they were trying to reference with this
1992 along with all the George Michael
stuff it did serve as a nice spiritual
sequel to that flash karaoke from back
in season one I'm surprised that they
haven't done that before
[Music]
number three curse of the earth totem so
they dig it up and it resurrects the
woman that Blackbeard killed once it
sort of amplified her powers so you get
a bit of a taste for what it can do I
mean it's poison ivy is probably the
best reference we could make all those
vines growing everywhere they finally
escaped they have a couple funny moments
like the Jew a rum I was wondering where
they were taking that because they kept
saying that name over and over and I'm
like what is this a reference to because
it didn't sound familiar but then by the
end of the episode they paid it off
that's what they were talking about they
were just building towards the reveal
that Amaya is now a brand of rum and
they just sort of shake it off like it's
no big deal so I love the way that they
treat changing time like sometimes it's
okay to mess with the timeline sometimes
it's not so they're gonna allow minor
edits every once in a while but number
two Wally formally becomes a legend we
learned that he can only get hangovers
for about three minutes at a time which
is pretty badass awesome speedster
metabolism rip calls him by his full
name Wallace West again they've only
been a couple people that have called
him that HR during season three is the
only other person that I can think of
even Joe I don't think has ever called
him Wallace West but he finally accepts
rips invitation to become a legend so
presumably right after this they're
going to meet the legends because they
have that device that they saw off of
Gary I totally love the fact that he
stole that off of him then pulled Gary's
pants down but number one of course is
the story about Ray Palmer trying to
help Nora than them pulling a fast one
on him so you can kind of see what's
going on here if you didn't know Brandon
Ralph is actually married to this
actress here Courtney in real life so it
sounds like they wanted to have some fun
together on screen so we'll probably get
that next week and why they probably
teased that moment when we saw the young
version of her character and they sort
of bonded over the Oklahoma song they
sang it together I'm wondering if
they're gonna actually try and redeem
her character by the end and Ray will
find some way to break through to her so
it'll be like them husband and wife on
screen having some fun together while at
the same time trying to do something
interesting with her character so
because of the way they teased Wally
being so powerful in this episode just
easily stealing all of rip hunters
things from the time bureau
that he'll be critical to helping c'est
vrai in next week's episode but let me
know in the comments what do you think
about all the comic book Easter eggs in
the way they use Wally West I think
it'll be a lot of fun and I'm sure
they'll find a way to replicate some of
that rocket fuel booze so he can get
drunk again before the end of the season
but what will happen is is there
supposed to be some infinity war stuff
happening tomorrow morning if any
footage drops I'll do a video for it but
otherwise there's a new episode of final
space which is done by olan Rogers he's
a pretty prominent youtuber so I'm
planning on doing a review video for
that and then obviously the flash is
back so I'll name a giveaway winner when
I post that flash video tomorrow so
while you wait for everything click here
tour it all about the Deadpool TV series
that's coming this year and click here
for brand new flash thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight